it's no secret that 2016's dr. strange
is a part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but just how connected is the
master of the mystic arts to his fellow
superheroes and comic legacy here are a
few Doctor Strange Easter eggs you may
not have noticed New York New York the
flow of time gets a little wacky and dr.
strange thanks to the influence of the
eye of agamotto and the Infinity stone
powering it but we can safely say that
the film takes place in a world that is
well aware of superheroes during a few
shots in the film we see the Avengers
tower standing tall over New York
however by the end of age of Ultron the
Avengers have abandoned the tower and
moved to upstate New York
like Rhinebeck hipsters either way hero
stuff is going on so strange isn't alone
war machine moments before Master
surgeon Stephen strange has the car
accident that changes his life he hears
about a 35 year old with a spine problem
and an experimental suit of armor and
despite an Easter egg dropped in
daredevil it's probably not stilt man
mostly because no one would care if
stilt man was paralyzed Tony Stark made
pretty sure that no one was flying
around using any of his designs by
blowing up his entire arsenal at the end
of Iron Man 3 and we know that poor ol
Rhodey suffered a pretty devastating
spinal injury during civil war while the
filmmakers have denied any connection
how many people are really hanging out
an experimental armor in the MCU
Shambhala what's this fine launcher
it's the Wi-Fi password we're not
savages the concept of Shambala isn't
unique to dr. stream as the mystical
otherworldly kingdom has existed in
religious texts for centuries not
coincidentally into Shambhala is also
the name of an important Doctor Strange
story from 1986 concerning not only the
death of the ancient one but also
featuring premier the one-handed Magic
Man from the temple in the movie while
the comics revealed that him here is
actually Wong's father the film flipped
the script in so many ways that it's not
likely that this relationship translated
to the big screen drum like most of
Marvel's heroes have done at one time or
another dr. Strange's also relinquished
his title and let someone else fly
around in his cloak of levitation for a
while in the film the now dead guardian
of the New York sanctum is simply called
drum eagle eared Marvel fans will
recognize the name as belonging to
brothers Jericho and Daniel drum the
latter of which was a Buddha hungin
comic book things happen and the two
were joined in spirit and become brother
voodoo at one point
Jericho drum takes possession of the eye
of agamotto and takes the name dr.
voodoo who also happens to be the
sorcerer supreme it doesn't last forever
but it's clear that the MCU is planting
magical seeds everywhere the Doctor
Strange movie previewed comics confirmed
that this dead guardian was in fact
Daniel drum not only that but the comics
also featured Tina Minoru as another
master of the mystic arts she's a secret
practitioner of magic in Marvel's
Runaways and mother a powerful witch
Nico Minoru so The Runaways have
basically been confirmed in the MCU and
psychic by dinosaurs can't be that far
behind which is the greatest thing ever
the Living Tribunal the hierarchy of
power and Marvel Comics is confusing and
even though there are only a few big bad
guys in the MCU it's already reaching
for flexing levels of power Thanos is no
slouch but he's not much without his
Infinity stones Dormammu seems like a
big deal but he also seems like a less
intelligent version of Galactus so far
so when Mordo mentions the staff of The
Living Tribunal you know stuff's gonna
get crazy this is the stuff
of the Living Tribunal though he's a bit
obscure the Living Tribunal is one of
Marvel's many godlike characters an
enormous all-powerful dude with a
floating head that has three faces he
essentially keeps all the multiverses
and balance and only has one being above
him in terms of power
no actually it's this guy and somehow
some part of the Living Tribunal is
captured in a wooden stick in the middle
of nowhere because magic
the wand of watoomb and the book of
vishanti dr. strange has a few signature
magical items among them are the eye of
agamotto which causes no end of trouble
for strange in both the film and comics
and the cloak of levitation curiously
missing is the book of Ashanti which is
basically Strange's Bible and
encyclopedia though it's probably locked
up in Wong's well-guarded library right
alongside the book that strange does use
the book of cogliostro if you've been
watching agents of shield you know that
there's another magical book floating
around the MCU at the moment as well the
dark hold which actually shares a few
pages with the book of Cagliostro not to
mention that the book of cogliostro has
a few pages that were actually written
by God and probably a few by James
Patterson we also get a glimpse of one
of Strange's other signature weapons the
wand of watoomb
even though it's wrong who wields the
item in defense of the hong kong sanctum
that weird Navi Horn stick is
unmistakable blu-ray replays will
probably reveal even more of Strange's
armoury locked up in the Bleecker Street
sanctum which by the way is located at
177 a just like in the comics Nick West
the jealous potato chip loving dr. Nick
West is actually a character right out
of the pages of a 2007 Doctor Strange
story called The Oath where he plays the
doctor who bungled Strange's busted up
hands beyond usefulness he begins
magical training just like strange but
he's a C student at best
eventually he accidentally kills someone
with magic and he and strange Duke it
out with West falling off a building to
his death and that scene where an astral
strange helps someone with an operation
on his own mortal body straight out of
the oath to mindless ones the Dark
Dimension basically has three main
inhabitants Dormammu his sister Umar and
the mindless Swami's those things are
dormammu's featureless gray cycloptic
hench things at the conclusion of Doctor
Strange we see Casillas and his minions
get sucked into the dark dimension
losing all their features in the process
and looking suspiciously like mindless
ones during their transformation with
glints of light replacing their faces it
seems likely that anyone who allies with
Dormammu and his promise of eternal life
will eventually be transformed into a
mindless one what does that mean for the
ancient one we may never know the doors
of perception the obligatory Stan Lee
cameo was so much more than just an old
dude reading on the bus the book that
Lee is giggling at is the doors of
perception by Aldous Huxley not only is
it a literal reference to strange
perception of reality being forced open
but the book is pretty much an essay
about a psychedelic drug trip which is
no small comment on both the dazzling
special effects of the movie and the
dark dimension that place looks like a
Steve Ditko drawing come to life and
it's practically the spitting image of
those 1970s third eye blacklight posters
Marvel used to sell for your parents
teenage drug dens oh thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel and watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to